欸，你可能沒想到，現在反而是那些小型企業，正在悄悄地在退休金這塊玩出新花樣，甚至超越那些大公司。
嗯？你說小公司？這出乎我意料。我一直以為退休金這種事，就是大企業才有資源、有能力去搞定的福利，小公司光是發薪水大概就夠吃力了。
對啊，這就是最讓人詫異的地方。過去大家總覺得，福利要好、要完整，就得找大公司。小公司能做的，頂多就是基本勞保，甚至可能連這都沒搞好。
怎麼說呢？大公司有規模經濟，可以跟金融機構談到更好的方案，還有專門的人力資源部門處理這些。小公司光是行政流程、法規遵循就夠頭痛了吧？
其實原文有提到，現在這情況已經改變了。像 ADP 的員工福利調查就顯示，退休儲蓄計畫在 2025 年已經變成第二重要的員工福利了，比非健康相關的福利還重要。
這麼說來，這對小公司競爭人才的壓力就更大了。如果連退休金都比不上大公司，那要怎麼留住人？
沒錯，這正是他們發揮的點。原文提到，現在的退休金方案變得更容易、更實用了。像是 SECURE 2.0 法案，擴大了稅收抵免，可以抵消掉大部分，甚至全部的啟動成本。
稅收抵免？這個聽起來是個誘因，但真的能讓小公司放手去做嗎？畢竟不只啟動成本，後續的管理費用、行政人力也都是錢啊。
這就是他們的創新點了。原文說，現在出現了「集體僱主計畫」，就是多個小型企業可以共用一個退休金計畫，這樣就能分攤成本，也能降低行政負擔。
集體僱主計畫…這個模式倒是有意思。等於把大公司的規模優勢，用聯盟的方式複製給小公司。那在操作上具體是怎麼做的？
他們其實很強調「簡化」和「個人化」。自動加入、自動提升儲蓄比例、還有透明的進度追蹤工具，再加上財務健康培訓，這些都讓員工更容易參與。
這些調整看似小細節，但確實會影響員工的參與度。不過，這些做法真的能讓小公司在福利待遇上，對大公司產生競爭優勢嗎？成本真的划算嗎？
原文裡面特別提到，科技的進步是關鍵。現在很多退休金方案都能跟薪資系統連結，管理行政自動化，甚至提供信託支持，大幅降低了日常管理負擔和風險。
我猜啦，重點不只是提供退休金，而是提供一個「讓員工覺得自己有未來」的感受。小公司可能無法像大公司一樣提供高薪，但在這種長期承諾上，或許能做得更好。
就是這個意思！原文也說，員工不只是為薪水留下，更是因為覺得自己「正在建立一個有未來的東西」。這會讓他們對公司文化產生更強烈的認同感。
所以如果我是個小公司的老闆或主管，我可以學到，即使資源有限，也能在福利設計上做出差異化。不一定要砸大錢，但要讓人感受到公司的用心和對未來的承諾。
對啊。你也可以想想看，如果把這個概念帶到自己的工作或生活裡，是不是也能提醒我們，不只看短期利益，也要為長遠的目標做規劃？
嗯，這點我是信了。就像我們個人理財一樣，自動儲蓄、定期檢視，看似簡單，長期下來效果卻很驚人。
好像也提醒了我們，有時候，小的改變和以人為本的設計，反而能帶來出乎意料的競爭優勢。